الانترنت صوت الاحتجاجات في ايران الذي
يصل اصداه الى العالم رغم محاوله النظام
اسكاته هذه المره من الفضاء
مئه محطه استقبال ارضيه لخدمه الانترنت
المؤمنه عبر شركه ستارلينج للاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل في ايران حاليا
هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس شركه سبيس اكس
الملياردير الامريكي
نشر فيها مقطع فيديو قال انه التقط في
شوارع ايران معتبرا انه الان توجد حريه
اكبر للنساء في اختيار ما اذا كنا يريدنا
تغطيه شعرهن له اعلان وماسك عن المئه جهاز
التي تعمل بالفعل في ايران تاتي كيفاء
بالوعد كان قطعه في سبتمبر الماضي اذا
اعلن حينها انه سيعمل على ايتاحه الانترنت
عبر شبكته للاقمار الصناعيه في ايران في
وقت تفرض فيه السلطات المزيد من القيود
على الانترنت لمنع ايصال صوت المتظاهرين
الى الخارج
وستعمل خدمه النطاق العريض المعتمده على
الاقمار الصناعيه في مساعده الايرانيين في
الالتفات على قيود المفروضه للوصول الى
الانترنت وبعض منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
وسط الاحتجاجات وهو ما سيكل مصدر ضغط جديد
على النظام الايراني